il ya parfois des mots qui reste plus
que d'autres c'est ce que vit
aujourd'hui michel cymes avec une
déclaration qui l'aurait fait au début
de la crise liée aux coronavirus c'est
la partie positive
à l'époque le célèbre médecin était
interrogé sur le govic 19 et la possible
propagation du virus en france une
propagation qu'il avait minimisé avec
les éléments dont il disposait à
l'époque pour ça reste une maladie qui
est bénigne dans la grande majorité des
cas un apaisement que beaucoup avait
résumé en indiquant que michel cymes
avait parlé d'une grippette
s'il n'a jamais employé ce mot cette
intervention pour minimiser le virus lui
colle aujourd'hui encore à la peau c'est
quand même un truc incroyable à chaque
fois que je vois mon nom dans la presse
ses cimaises qui a parler de grippette
je défie quiconque quiconque de trouver
une interview de moi un mot de moi où
j'ai parler de grippette
et lorsqu'on lui reproche il ya quelques
semaines à peine d'expliquer chez
laurent ruquier sur france 2 que dans la
rue ils ne portent pas de maths
une fois encore le médecin s'agace
j'étais en train de tourner une fiction
en pleine auvergne je sors de mon gîte
je rencontre des écureuils effectivement
ne portait pas de masque
voilà c'est tout mais dans paris je ne
porte t il avec moi une mise au point
qui il l'espère va calmer les esprits
autour de ses déclarations
prenez à bon moi je vais te dire si
l'effet boomerang
ouais l'a tellement fait le mariole
escudé bientôt télé et ceux qui les
critiquent ce matin c'est les mêmes tout
fait aussi les marieurs sur les plateaux
télé voilà il a assez il a continué à
parler du professeur à ou dans la presse
regardez c'était dans 20 minutes
regardez ce qu'a dit michel cymes
compter un an irresponsables michel
cymes attaque le professeur à ou michel
cymes sort de ses gonds très irrité par
les dires de son confrère marseillais
qu'est-ce que vous amènera à l'uruguay
tu es obligé d'avoir les dogues savent a
commencé alors à mais cette fois il est
allé encore ce qu'il s'est attaqué à mon
équipe à vous et il s'est attaqué
notamment maroni regardez oui regardez
le chroniqueur n'est pas citée que
pensez vous de regarder que pensez vous
des gens télé qui disent que vous
devriez j'imagine que vous faites
allusion à la bande de tpm p je ne vise
personne mais je pense que certains
chroniqueurs ferait mieux d'aller cuvée
leur pastis sur le feu aux portes de
donner leurs éditions passées
[Musique]
alors tu vois encore un qui me connaît
pas comme lui je ne bois jamais de paris
[Applaudissements]
j'ai d'abord qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez que dans le q qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on appelle michel simard
c'est parti on appelle michel qui va me
répondre mais bon bonjour c'est bien sûr
de lui et on va le rappeler c'est bon
c'est bon bien sûr balle rapide voilà je
voulais laisser un message qui s p moi
je supporte ban et tu commences à ses
basiques yves abord le pâtissier le
prend mais quelle corde alors d'abord
joué par apple on va rapper ouais c'est
ça une corps mais je suis dur on a été
basiques sur lui aussi un fragment d'os
x oui mais moi il est sur rtl on appelle
on rappelle michel pas d'eau à les
prendre en compte
allô allô allô oui michel cymes oui
bonjour michel cymes et cyril hanouna
oui j'ai bidouillé libre mais sur 120 on
est sûr c'est évident on touche pas à
mon poste
en fait il ya rené malleville dont vous
parlez voilà qui a parlé vous avez parlé
lui c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas en super
bons termes avec vous et rené aimerait
répondre à ce que vous avez dit dont je
crois que c'est dans 20 minutes
concernant les chroniqueurs de tpm
puisqu'il s'est senti un peu visés ouais
alors madame oui oui oui j'habite lui on
en irak j'imagine que vous faites est
liée à la ban de tp mais je pense que
certains chroniqueurs ferait mieux
d'aller qui vais le parti ce lieu pas si
c'est à moi que tu pas souhaité dire tu
me connais très mal je ne vois jamais de
partir et thé allusion dans la com qui
te les garder parce qu'il ya toujours
attaquer le proviseur raul et c'est pour
ça que j'étais jeune j'ai parlé de toi
mais si j'avais si calmes et un peu plus
mesuré dans ses propos avaient route et
ben ça aurait mieux aller j'aurais fermé
ma gueule
il était là je te dit tu es petit les
allusions à la cog travail était sujet
avant de parler
contrôle interne et sur les sauts
répondent michel s'il vous plaît michel
cymes de bon là je comprends absolument
rien du tout alors de cyril hanouna donc
oui à mon pote alors rené malleville où
je connais un petit peu léger parti j'ai
parlé du professeur raoul effectivement
et j'ai évoqué marseille j'ai jamais
parlé de rené malleville a encore moins
du pastis la caisse ayant déjà nuit
alors qu'il buvait de l'anisette mais il
me passe t-il jamais cancha fils du
colonel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'allais me dégonfler devant lui je veux
remercier une moyenne assez lente il le
fait très bien
tout ce qu'ils ont cru que les jeunes
les modes des gommes fait alors et ses
imports article info michel sapho artix
info michel cymes tout est faux a plongé
dans le vieux port comme un mail à tana
jeter prouver que c'est vrai mais si
c'était vrai et bella brown
[Applaudissements]